hello and welcome to Android design in
action my name is Roman Nurik hey guys
adam crush and unfortunately Nick
butcher is stuck at devoxx and trying to
figure out a way to join us via Google+
Hangout so I he may join at some point
hopefully quite soon but we're going to
give them a few extra minutes but for
those of you who are new to the show for
those of you who are new to the show
this Lawrence it seems like Nick is
joining his neck joint producer pete
nick has joined hopefully he can hear us
yes there is yeah hey did you hear me
finally yeah we were for those that
weren't watching we were having some
trouble getting Nick connected but Nick
is not connected live via devoxx now
you're gonna do a quick introduction hey
good yeah absolutely so I'm here at the
DevOps conference in Antwerp so it's
been a fantastic kind of Java face
conference a hearing releasing the world
Java and talking some of that Android
which give the code lab yesterday thank
people have a sick data between their
android apps using google drive in the
background and as possible to hang out
with some of the android framework
engineers like Ramon key people that in
here about all the latest improvements
in the UI toolkit so pretty nice
conference awesome and we're very
envious that we can't be there with you
Nick but we're hoping you guys are
having a great conference so for those
of you that are new to Android design in
action in this show we look at existing
apps and sometimes we look at existing
categories of apps and look at what you
know types of design renovations or
design reimagining we can do for them on
this episode we're going to cover
instant messaging and we're not going to
go too deeply into that because we have
some more important stuff to talk about
and that is a community redesigns so
last week on Android design in action we
gave kind of a mission a challenge to
the community to take a nap that you
know that you've seen before and
potentially that you maybe don't like
the layout for and rethink it redesign
it yourself you know use your photoshop
skills use your you know sketching
skills and
and put up a public redesign of that app
and we've gotten a lot of contestants
and washing that really contestants a
lot of entries and we're going to take a
look at some of those today and then as
well as talk about the the tablet UI
stencils that we promise to give away
before so let's get started and jump
into instant messaging so what we did
was we took a look at rather than take a
look at existing apps like group me and
trillian that were covered in last
week's app clinic we wanted to think of
what would a hypothetical awesome IM
client or messaging client look like and
so we came up with a few screen mocks
for what that could look like we didn't
give it a name or anything so it's just
called hypothetical messaging app and
you can see here this is kind of one of
the the key I guess hero screens for the
app it's basically the conversation view
in this view your you know you're
communicating with a bunch of different
people in this case you're Luke
Skywalker talking to all your friends
and the point here is that we didn't
want to really emphasize all the chrome
around instant messaging like all the
action bar stuff and the action buttons
that we talked about usually you really
want to focus on how you present the
content so here you can notice that
there's three different types of content
really there's you know there's rich
information about a place that you've
shared a rich kind of audio snippet with
I guess transcribed text and then a
bunch of photos that you submitted so
that's kind of at a very basic level
what this screen shows you and it's
really just a conversation view you guys
have any uh preliminary comments before
we keep gun no okay all right I'm
something quick I just really like the
fact that there's a rich content
included here directly um I think we've
moved beyond having just texting instant
messaging clients and now we have phones
which you can take pictures you can
record audio obviously sharing places is
very important so I just really like how
the sort of different content types of
in brought out here and all of this
isn't new existing apps like group me
already do this so you can share your
current location or share actually don't
know if you can share a place but you
can I think you can check in with
Foursquare for example and you can also
share pictures so existing apps do
this but we would really like to see is
more and more apps doing this because
it's no longer lucky said Adam about
just text you really want to share
content or objects in the next screen
you'll notice that you know when you
touch the little attach icon on the
bottom left you can be presented with
things like take a photo record some
audio and then maybe automatically
transcribe it and then you know
obviously attach location things like
that one of the coolest things that I
really want instant messaging clients to
start thinking about is streaming video
and this is kind of interesting because
you have things like Google Plus
hangouts where you can you know
basically create a shared meeting space
with your friends and with your family
and all be on video at the same time but
some something for some reason I was
thinking about you know like what about
those push-to-talk days you know sprint
nextel where you'd push say something
and everybody would hear it streaming
live what if you could do that with
video so I did a quick mock-up let's
just skip this one did a quick mock-up
of what that could look like so you
press like stream I guess you press the
attached icon and select stream video
from your camera it immediately changes
the composed box into a basically a
preview of your front facing camera as
you're talking it's streaming live in
the stream of the conversation to
everybody else and then for you as the
recorder you kind of just see you got to
just see this kind of live token in the
stream and then maybe as people are
saying stuff as they're responding to
your video they can kind of you know
type and type in type in oil maybe stick
your video feed to the top of their
window that wasn't mocked up of course
so just to be clear the videos actually
playing in line in the conversation that
right and would there be like a full
screen mode as well yeah yeah so I mean
like we didn't mock this up but I think
if we had some more time we totally do
this but the idea would be like you're
streaming video it's not like a you know
actually it is recorded so you know
after after you press this checkbox
indicate that you're done that video is
just a token that's playable kind of
like a YouTube video or or whatever
that's attached but in line you know in
the stream if you're if somebody's
currently streaming video you can you
know watch it in line or
so this is something that I just haven't
seen other ABS do and I think that it's
something that like think about ways to
compose rich content not only view rich
content but compose it right and so
another one of these another one of
these screenshots or mocks you have this
kind of composition window that can
accept tokens so let's say you paste the
URL you know what if you just paste the
token indicating that this is a URL
object and you know maybe a place is
also kind of a place to intercept so
this is just something that I think
folks should think about yeah I think
it's cool to with the images as well
that you can scroll those in line yeah
so I mean if you have if you have where
is it let's go back here right if you
have a set of like six or seven images
that you've attached then you should
probably support the share intent right
so if i'm in galleria selects 8 images i
should be able to share to my messaging
client you know if i get a i guess a
converse or a message with 8 images i
should be able to swipe through them
left and right in line that's awesome i
it so many app says like a lot of I
guess you call it pogos get sticking
where you have to go up and down in and
out and have all these kind of context
switches so I love the idea of like
staying within a fluent conversation but
being able to kind of take in all the
media types it's cool yeah and this is
something that the gmail recently did
with the update with the android 4.2
update gmail now lets you have this kind
of mini gallery view within an email
message right so if you get an email
message with 10 attachments you don't
have to jump in to see each individual
one you basically have a horizontally
swipeable gallery for the email messages
of the attachments that were there so
rather than spend too much time and
instant messaging again the the main
event is coming up the last thing I just
want to talk about is the tablet UI that
we've design here so again this is
fairly standard a very simple master
detail view where you know on the left
you have
a master list of all your conversations
and then on the right you have your
conversation view now the important
thing to note here and this is kind of
where the interesting part of tablets
comes in is there's a lot of ways to
optimize for a tablet you know on the
Left obviously we're combining screens
but on the right you'll notice that the
presentation of the conversation itself
is slightly different we've we've
increased the padding the spacing the
margins to kind of let the let the core
content float freely within your bounds
so it's not kind of compressed into one
of the corners and edges so like the
spacing between you know the
conversation and the avatar is increased
between the avatar and the kind of the
side of the screen and then everything
is just bigger like these images are no
longer a one to one aspect ratio they're
kind of slightly wider to again account
for the extra with you have on its
screen and then there's just like
everything is larger right so this this
composition window or this composition
bar at the bottom is I think I forgot
the exact dimensions it shows but is
about one and a half to two times as
tall for a much larger more accessible
touch target and then at the very top
this presence bar that shows you all the
people that are currently viewing the
conversation as well as all the people
that are involved in the conversation
that's also slightly larger to give the
thumbnails more space to breathe so
that's kind of just one example of how
you could take something as simple as a
list of messages and and turn it into a
great tablet UI Before we jump into our
main event talking about all the awesome
stuff that the community is done
anything else you guys want to talk
about in terms of IM and messaging
clients um what I guess one thing I want
to mention was um there's a lot of
popular IM clients out there on the Play
Store but for some reason like the most
popular ones typically do a pretty poor
job at at the actual presentation and
design maybe because they've been around
for a long time maybe because they focus
more on the functionality I'm not sure
but I you know personally I'd really
love a client that just had a great
design and work
really really well yeah and like this
for example I think also just on top of
that just getting the details right like
making sure notifications work making
sure you know things are a quick thing
that you never miss anything that's also
important but on top of that you know to
to go above and beyond your competition
having a you know a great tablet UI and
having a strong you know visual
presentation of the of the content
itself of the messages and your friends
that you're talking with that's going to
put you above and beyond alright so
let's move on to the the main event so
as we mentioned in the beginning last
week we set out a challenge to the
community to take a look at one of the
apps you use regularly or one of the
apps you just don't like how it looks or
whatever and redesign it you know think
think about what you know if they were
of that company were to hire you to you
know redesign the entire app what would
that look like what are you know what
are some of the key things you'd use and
the response was just crazy phenomenal
over whelming has so impressed we
thought we were going to get you know
four maybe five but it was very very
impressive yeah we got a lot of
submissions and if you'd like you can
actually check them all out now if you
go on google+ and search for these two
hashtags here for public posts tagged
with those you'll see all these entries
we've done a quick kind of collage of
what all the entries look like and we'll
just quickly show you a few so this is
just like you know all the great content
of the community has come up with really
phenomenal there are some obviously
there's some tablet layouts here we'll
talk about catch that bus in a moment
IMDb by paul burke was a great job
last.fm will talk about in good food
which is a nexus 7 specific layout and
Nick I believe you you've looked at good
food specifically right yeah I've been
there talking to the developers of it
and I think there's some really good
ideas and this redesign yeah just a song
yeah and I mean a lot of these
developers are gonna have to look at
some of these screenshots now say let's
get let's get cracking let's uh let's
figure out how to implement some of this
so overall really great work and there's
another
another page of this again lots of
tablet you eyes this one down here at
the bottom left this is for speed test
right and we'll talk about that you
androidguys lots of good stuff going on
here so great work over all these are
the entrance that participated and
submitted something so again round of
applause for the mall I think overall is
a phenomenal job at a community and then
regarding the stencil we originally said
that we we're going to give out 10 of
the UI stencils from you I stencils com
so first of all before we jump into who
we're giving things to you can of course
you know purchase them at you I stencils
calm and click on the android tablet kit
so that that should be available today
but for all the entrants that submitted
something basically everybody here will
be sending you guys a UI stencil from
you I stencils calm and will be reaching
out to you on google plus 2 to find out
you know your shipping address and all
that so great job job really well done
and you're all getting stencils so with
that let's move on to some of the
highlights we wanted to pick a few of
the community entries and look at them
in detail and say a few words about what
we loved about them so first is whatsapp
Adam going to talk about what's that
yeah so this is an app actually
personally used quite heavily I guess
grudgingly use it it's it's one of those
apps where a ton of my friends across
the world kind of use it a lot so I'm
sort of forced to use it it's it's
actually pretty good in terms of
functionality like it's very responsive
it's very quick and it's very simple to
use but the design is definitely lacking
they suddenly have the menu button of
shame down the bottom there it's a very
dated looking UI and and it's just it I
don't think they have much sort of
visual flair I guess it's it's very
plain so the redesign of is very very
nice by maximilian Solomon hopefully I'm
not slaughtering that name pronunciation
but it's it's a it's a really nice
reimagining of the app with the whole
earthy me let's see if we can just
in here a bit probably want to shift it
over so when I block yeah yeah it
actually uses a few things that Roman
put into the the hypothetical messaging
up as well so the one thing I'm not sure
about actually is the top tabs what that
would be useful but i really like just
the conversation list here plus the
split action bar down the bottom for the
quick actions it's worth noting as well
that those split actions down the bottom
would be evenly spaced you know if you
implemented using the standard split
action bar on Android but yeah it's it's
nice you've got the sort of snippet of
text there with the emoji still showing
you've got the unread message count
showing there directly and instead of
using a long press to trigger the
contextual action menu they've got the
little triangle down the bottom right
corner to signify that they're sort of
additional actions that you could take
on that particular conversation and then
a bunch of the additional actions have
been collapsed under the overflow menu
there that you wouldn't sort of
necessarily access all the time guys any
thoughts on the screen this I just I
just personally like and this is a theme
throughout the the choice of colors and
the color palettes that were chosen
throughout all the contestants were
really really strong I thought that kind
of the combination of the like a dark
teal and green color it fits in with the
branding of whatsapp I mean I don't know
too much about the the company in the
app but it seems to fit with that kind
of that green brand and in the original
screen you see here on the left there is
no hint to that at all so I thought the
branding here is particularly good and
obviously using the hollow elements is
awesome but I think even more
interesting was it was the second screen
race in this screen this is kind of the
the conversation detail view which shows
all the different messages that have
been going back and forth between you
know you and your friends and i think
that the redesign of this screen
particularly for me just you know was a
stark contrast yeah definitely um
so I think this is quite good I mean
even this these little details like
having the the little triangular
call-outs include part of the image so
like you know the simplest way to
implement something like this is you
know you just have the call out which is
always white and then if there's an
image then you show the image to the
right of that but here the developer or
the designer has shown that you know
let's not do that let's actually make
the image part of the call-out and again
it gives you this feeling of immersive
pneus that it's it's an image that's
taking up the entire space that it's
kind of like a this freeform piece of
content I can't really put it into two
great words but that's that's the
feeling I get from that Nick anything
else you want to add to the what's at
the awesome what's have designed or
should we move on it's just I like it
it's very clean it looks like an Android
app to me now good job awesome alright
so next we have last.fm and a last.fm
this is the the old screen so you're
what you're currently looking at is the
current app last.fm is a is a basically
an app that lets you kind of look at
radio stations or I guess online radio
stations and play them and and whatnot
kind of similar to pandora it's been
around for quite a long time the
actually know the one of the former
developers the app is written really
well the app is actually open source so
it's it's a quite a good strong app in
terms of using Android features but the
design is kind of dated so kind of dated
isn't probably a mystical bit so you can
see that you know they're using the old
aclarar style tabs or using these white
face and carrots and and really just the
the content screens aren't really that
immersive you just have seized of white
and you know splotches of text here and
they're really tiny images you know in
the list view that so I think if we were
to give out awards at all i think the
the starkest contrast between old and
new goes to this one so i hope i'm
pronouncing your name right wallner has
done an awesome job be designing this
here's the new screen so you can see
that you know complete shift in terms of
you know color palette in terms of
content first right i mean the images
just immediately stick out right like
that's the first thing you see is the
content but also i mean he's done a
great job introducing some of that
branding right
this the color palette here is very
strong it's kind of that red dark gray
white theme and it's really strong it's
a really good job introducing that color
palette here some is specific things I
want to point out and this is something
that it doesn't get enough attention i
think is you know when you have list
items or grid items basically collection
views spend some time on the individual
layout for each row or each cell here
there's a really interesting
presentation where you kind of couple
the content the album art as well as who
is sharing that so this is kind of a
great way to to show two pieces of
content layered on top of another and
then as you can see here there's just
tons of you know tons of that red shown
everywhere and it's really kind of
really powerful you know 'king that
brand everywhere throughout a couple
couple of details I've likes Korra as
well I think they've done a really nice
job of them with a brandy let you say
extending the color palette throughout
but also and I don't see people do this
enough is having a full-on like last.fm
logo on the top the whole screen but
then you know you don't need to have
that taking up a lot of space throughout
every level of the hierarchy so I love
the way there's going to put the
collapse representation on their kind of
child screens which allows you to use
the title more space more effectively
which i think is a really nice detail
they don't very well there yeah
definitely definitely and this is
something that the i/o app does so I
mean if you want to see how it's done in
terms of implementation I just take a
look at the google i/o app which is open
source and it does this showing a logo
on your home screen and then just an
icon which is again customizable doesn't
have to be your launcher icon just an
icon on detail screens and category
screens so moving on from last.fm the
next app is speed test Adam even talked
about pizza yeah speed test for those of
you haven't used this app it's it's a
pretty simple app at least at least on
the Android side I'm sure there's a
bunch of infrastructure on the server
side but it's used just for measuring
the speed of the connection that you
have so it could be measuring Wi-Fi
connection could be measuring 3g 4g
whatever connection that you have to the
server so it really does just two things
it measures your speed
does a speed test and it stores your
historical test so you can see you know
where you were which speeds you got it's
actually fairly popular you know people
have used this service at least in the
US for quite a while we don't have a
shot of the original app here um I know
this might almost get the award for
stark contrast as well the interesting
thing about the current app is that it
actually locks itself to particular
dimensions I'm not even sure how they
did I think they would have had to go
out of their way specifically to do that
so even on my Nexus 4 it shows in a
small cropped window with black space
around it which is really peculiar it's
almost like frame not even letter but
yeah it's framed in like black pixels
yeah definitely and if you learn it up
on a tablet it does the same thing it's
just this tiny little window in the
middle of the screen so I like this just
because it really simplifies the the
look and feel it brings the content out
and and it sticks to sort of the you
know the roots of what the app is trying
to do here measure the speed and show
your historical entries um it also has
elements of the new clock app I think to
it and new stopwatch app that ship with
Android 4.2 which i think is a good
thing yeah are you going here so I mean
not not much else to come in here other
than I think it looks really nice the
whole thing is great and it really
sticks to a sort of sort of main
navigation that we would recommend for
an app like this menu about an action
bar tabs and then and then to content
pains on the tablet UI I think the other
thing I just want to point out for the
tablet UI is look how much you can do
just changing metrics just changing
dimensions the only difference and I'm
guessing that the assets are probably
the same they're probably not even using
any assets there's probably some custom
drawing if you implement this but the
font sizes are slightly larger the
spacing between elements is slightly
larger the size of that circle is
obviously larger but then just like it's
really just about spacing font size and
in just dimensions and metrics and
obviously having if you're showing
images you know showing those images at
full resolution but it's really shows
that shows the power of what you can do
with just dimensions so for developers
out there if you just extract your
dimensions in two dimension resources
you don't even have to create a tablet
specific layout in a lot of case
you just change the dimensions for
tablets yep good job Glen Barker so yeah
I guess the takeaway for the designers
for that is he I don't be scared about
you know having signed it looks similar
but then you call out different
switching points at which you say the
texts I should be larger because that's
really easy for developers to do yeah
exactly and maybe like we should
probably do it a future episode and how
to like best annotate that in your
mock-ups that's definitely something
that like it requires some logic like if
this then that maybe we should talk
about that a little more but anyway
let's move on to the next step since
we're running a little long time IMDb
Nick do you wanna talk about I'm to be
yeah absolutely so I what I really liked
about this redesign in particular was
they didn't just not just but in only
apply hollow look and feel to it they
also took a stab at and looking at the
information architecture so I say they
it's Paul Burke good job Paul he looked
at the way that kind of people were he
and his friends he says use IMDb and
definitely resonated with me that you're
quite often using mobile in a different
context than you are using the website
and he's kind of really rearranged the
hierarchy of the information to make
things like you know you're watching
maybe want to see what who the actor is
or whatever movies they've been in make
that really really quick and make and
he's used images really well I think
throughout the app to make it very quick
to see what's going on in fish de kind
of like parsley app yeah and I mean you
you can't see this here in one of his
markups he basically hid all the trivia
information like the birth date and so
on for the actor hid that under an
expandable item here at the top and
that's kind of it's it's it's nice right
to be able to you know focus on the
stuff that you immediately want to see
on mobile and you probably want to see
oh my god i just saw somebody is that
joseph gordon-levitt you want to be able
to you know tell by looking at some
photos maybe you're not as interested
about when they were born or you know
where they grew up or something on the
go so definitely a kind of a good
rethinking of the entire experience on
mobile what is was the user trying to
get at and then when you touch on one of
these movie titles it kind of gives you
a very quick pop up I've probably use
something besides a pop up but it shows
you're very quick pop up showing you the
immediately important things like the
rating and then
I think the metascore so like obviously
you want to see if if movies are good
you know on the go you're deciding
between something so you know making
that rating number or star meter or
whatever really prominent is probably
pretty important yeah generally dialogue
not the answer but I would like to see
that perhaps is an ever-expanding place
a bit like he has for the extra
information about the answer that could
be quite fun mm-hmm okay I think the
last that we have today is catch that
bus and i'll just briefly just mention
the one thing I loved about this is just
the focus on the different screens
basically the and actually this is
implemented ready the designer /
developer as part of the redesign
actually re-implemented everything so if
you go ahead and download catch the bus
this is what it looks like its design in
action Wow exactly design and
implementation in out but the one thing
I left here is that you know that he
clearly thought about the different
screen sizes and that's something that's
that's more and more important as you
have devices like Nexus 10 nexus 7 out
there and the other thing that I loved
here is the color choices again the the
single accent color where they're using
yellow as the accent color is really
unique and it really stands out
throughout the app you can see that kind
of yellow is everywhere yellows in the
tab selections yellow is in the the core
iconography and in the launcher icon so
I think it's a 18 in this setting screen
I think it's just the only way he'd cut
some of the switches in the settings
screen really yeah our branding
mm-hmm-hmm for sure did you yeah so
great work I think that's the last one
we had any other notes around the
community stuff guys I think that some
of the others were also fantastic we
just didn't have time to cover all of
them but great job by yeah really really
great yeah I think I've been really
enjoying is actually just a seeing a
community of people evolving around the
hash Android design hashtag certainly on
google+ and i'd love to see this
continue it's been fantastic to see all
the conversation it seen people dive
into other people's redesigns and
offering feedback and then people you
know its rating all their designs it's
been that's been incredible I should say
you know if you get feedback on your
design don't take that as like somebody
sizing you it's really you know we're in
general trying to provide kind of
positive feedback and just now learn
from whether what others are doing if
they give you criticism that's you know
that's a totally positively minded
they're not trying to tell you that you
suck or anything about just before we
sign off I really want to quickly give a
shout out to taylor who was actually
also one of the entrance he submitted a
redesigned from google finance and he
just this morning released a sketching
kit update basically this is a sketching
kit that you can print out onto a4 paper
it's kind of like a template that shows
you the real sizes of the nexus for the
nexus 10 Nexus 7 I think he's got all
the Nexus devices in there so if you're
interested in doing some sketching
definitely download Taylor's kit so with
that I think that's it for this week's
episode Nick thanks for joining from the
conference it's been fun glad I could
find a stable internet connection yeah
they're pretty pretty remarkable that
you haven't dropped off yeah good work
and not really designed years but uh the
Nexus devices the new next Nexus devices
are on sale today so happy Nexus day
everyone and indeed i'll be buying some
as soon as they're available in the US
all right well that's a fragile design
thanks for coming thanks for showing up
and thanks for watching my name is Roman
Nurik Adam Kosh and nicollet yeah thanks
guys like those guys next week right